wait before I do anything you see how it
says Bob there good good because I
getting so many [ __ ] message has been
you copy blah blah blah because you call
him Bob it's okay I'm gonna let this one
slide because you are beautiful isn't
that right Bob
what there's a [ __ ] dumb buck okay
you might feel a little headache Bob but
that's normal Tomahawk Chop I was going
so well
oh no way there's a brain in there oh
man this uh I I done oh we have to cut
it off oh [ __ ] why is it not working I
don't get it
ah better hurry up give me the drill I'm
a professional I can't work with this
yes ah come on baby
ah [ __ ] this go time what the [ __ ]
ah Bob you look so good tonight
what what you're gonna be so [ __ ]
smart after this we [ __ ] did it
yeah looks fine yeah I think I put it on
right I'm not shy I hope you bros
enjoyed leave a man that your dad is
[ __ ] is she sound like a man